foreign
I want to know what you do once a month
or what would you benefit from
remembering to do once a month so
changing the air filter to our air
conditioner I used to do that every
month where we live before now ours is
almost impossible to change and it's a
giant one so we actually have that set
for every six months but I used to
change it out because we lived in Los
Angeles before every month I would pull
it out it was super dirty so I would
change that right the first of each
month I would um I charge our safe we
have a safe at our home where we keep
all of our
um
um what are we keep in our safe
important yeah yeah there you go yeah
also we also charge our toys once a
month you can take that however you'd
like maybe it's Elmo's toys maybe it's
bex's and my toys we did have one box
when we were moving I said adult toys on
it and Ella was like oh and she just
read the word toys she's like I have
more toys I know Ella those are not for
you oh well here's another thing I do I
refill the soap in every bathroom even
if it's not empty so I'll go to the
kitchen I'll go to the guest bathroom
I'll go to the master bath and I will
fill up the soap dispensers on the first
of each month that way the 11th doesn't
roll by and all of a sudden it's been
several months and I'm like oh this
stupid thing is empty we never have an
empty soap dispenser as a result oh um
also on the first of the month I will
check expiration dates you and I did a
whole podcast episode about expired
things and in that podcast we talked
about many of the things that we don't
even know are expired like physical
Goods like maybe the clothes that I
don't wear anymore maybe those have
expired in my life or maybe we even have
expired relationships but to get more
literal we go to our fridge into our
medicine cabinet and on the first of the
month we say okay oh man these pickles
have expired or this milk has expired or
this medication this aspirin has expired
let's go ahead and get rid of it and by
get ready we give it to Ryan because he
said takes all the expired yes I like I
like to live life on the edge
so what else uh do you have that you
would need a reminder once a month a
once a month reminder would be helpful
let us know in the comments what about
you Alabama or Ryan do you have anything
that stands out to you
oh uh
uh I do while you have time to think I
have definitely picked up the toothbrush
and soap refilling habit from you it has
made my life so much easier because I
hate when things run out here in the
studio I actually have a schedule where
uh every month I charge our ring
security camera so that's part of my
routine is like the first podcast of
every month
um it's also same thing for spraying
with bugs there's a lot of bugs in Los
Angeles and Mallory does not like bugs
so that is something that has given me a
great ease of Mind of just having you
know uh something that is organic and
very natural as far as repellents a lot
of like citrusy kind of smells mints and
lavenders most bugs don't like it keeps
the termites away yes and it smells
lovely for most people yes
uh my contacts I gotta change this out
once a month and I learned that the hard
way and it's funny because Mariah she
used to work at like an ear nose and
throat ear Eye Nose and Throat yeah yeah
ENT and uh she would always get on me
about not changing my contacts because I
would just leave them in until
you know they started to get a little
blurry oh or like you know like until
they weren't until I could not use them
and she was like I'm telling you you're
gonna get an eye infection oh my uh
whatever and eventually got an eye
infection
well that's so now I changed my contacts
once a month to avoid getting eye
infections well that's good yeah that is
the once a month rule we have 16 other
rules for living with less you can find
them at the minimalists.com you just
click on the resources page there the
bunch of free resources you can download
like The 30-day minimalism game calendar
the free ebook 15 ways to write better
and of course the minimalist rule book
16 ways to or 16 rules for living with
less did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalists
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free